how to get your team to work together so
I got a great question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys
fir n who wrote in to say I went thanks
to your passion and skills I've been
walking through a few of your videos and
I'm still trying to find an answer how
can I help engaging teams that are far
from working together they keep
confronting while they have the solution
if they stay united cheers for rent okay
so to summarize its you have a team
that's not working well together how do
you get them to work together so that
they can find the solution if they are
united they will find the solution how
do you make that happen number one is
get the right people you need to get the
right people on the team and quite
honestly if your team is constantly
fighting and they're bickering and
they're not achieving their common goal
then you need to get rid of somebody
it's not working it's not the right team
and that may be harsh and that may not
be what you want to hear and you can
force people to work together but when
was the last time you did great work
when you were forced to work with
somebody who you didn't like when was
the last time that happened and when you
work with people who you love who you're
feeling of vibe with how much greater is
the quality of that work it's amazing so
why do you want to be surrounded by
people who you don't like who aren't
contributing who you fight with compared
to people who you can grow with and
create amazing things with and so it may
be painful short term but honestly your
best solution is you need to get the
right people who will work together
because you can you can force it right
you can come up with strategy you can
say okay let's all sit in the room and
let's talk about it and let's try to
understand each other and that might
help a little bit but again you will not
create great things working with people
who you don't have chemistry with so
stop trying to force it and instead get
the right people on board your team this
is a classic mistake a lot of
entrepreneurs make they hire for skills
and not values I need a web programmer
so I'm going to go out and hire coder
I need a sales person I'm going to hire
sales person and you look for the skills
right you look for
this person has ten years program and
experience oh this person was VP at
sales at this other company and they
grew it from a hundred thousand to ten
million in sales great and so you hire
that skill set but you don't hire the
values and then what's going to happen
is your team comes with all sorts of
different values and they're not going
to work well together so you need to get
the right team together and not just
hire four skills but hire four values
number two stand for something your
company yourself you need to stand for
something important you to understand
what your one word is and build around
it and if your team all feels the same
way and you know this mission that
you're on you're much more likely to be
successful here's a quick example so at
my company I hire four values I hire for
people who love entrepreneurs if you
don't love entrepreneurship you're not
going to work well at my company it's
all we do right if you don't love what
we stand for if you don't love believing
in entrepreneurs if you're not an
optimistic person you will not fit in
with what we do you'll think this is a
stupidest company ever but if you love
entrepreneurs and you believe in them
and you see them as being the champions
of the future then you're going to love
this company you're going to love it and
so I asked everybody what the one word
is and it's funny story obviously mine
is believe I usually have the belief
shirts on Christina who's my video
editor she makes all these videos she
produces them she puts them on YouTube
hi Christina I asked her what her one
word is and when her birthday was and
she has the same birthday as me May 20th
and her one word is believe and she
almost had a tattooed on her arm when
she was younger before she met me how
crazy is that right
her one word is believe she's one of the
same day as me you know is it surprising
that we work well together no right we
have different skill sets but we work
well together because we're aligned
around the same thing and so your team
has to be aligned they have to have
either the same word or sister words at
least so that they will work well
together your company stands or
something important and they can allow
right so all of us have different skill
sets right Christina does great videos
Jason might have bought a strategy and
execution a deal might be programming a
DS might be doing some some Adwords or
SEO stuff a GT might be working with our
authors between content everybody has
their own role we have you know ten
people working with us but we're all
trying to help entrepreneurs and we just
sees the world through our own lens and
we attack from different angles we're
all working towards the same thing if
your company doesn't stand for anything
important the every reason to often do
their own thing and say my way is the
best no my way is the best they're not
working together so you have to have
your company stand for something
important number three is empower them
you want to empower your team to make
decisions and be creative and try stuff
and pet stuff because you know what
here's news for you you don't have all
the answers so you better start
listening to your team and let them get
more engaged with the process and give
them a little rope to play with if you
empower your team it's surprising how
creative they can be and how much great
stuff they can come up with so here's an
example so since you guys are watching
videos I'm working on new video project
has me released yet haven't talked about
it yet
we'll see what happens when early
development stage and I gave my early
vision for it to Christina and she
started working on it and she came back
with something that was a totally
different spin on it than what I was
expecting what I saw in my head this key
Mack is totally different but I loved it
it's totally unique angle and we're
working with it and so I would have
never got that we're gonna have a
greater product the greater end result
because of that I would never have come
if she didn't feel comfortable to
explore with it rather did empower her
to go do it so you have to do it this
way is the only way we're ever going to
do things then you're gonna get what you
want but you're not going to get the
best product you're not going to get the
best end result and you're not going to
have a happy team right imagine you're
working for somebody and say this is the
only way to do it zero creativity zero
empowerment my way or that's it you
think that's going to be a
employee working with you now they're
going to make mistakes and there are
some things that I am you know anal
about and I need to have it a certain
way and so you know we'll make it that
way on some things but for the most part
I like having my team being able to go
out and explore and try stuff and we end
up with much better product and a team
that loves what they're doing so
remember get the right people stand for
something and empower them believe for
those who are watching like this video
please support me by clicking the link
in the description you can leave a
comment let me know what you think if
you have a question leave it below make
your video response and click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon